this is the natural conclusion of the
participation trophy generation
yeah i i think it's funny because i
remember a long time ago people
complained about participation trophies
you get a trophy for just standing there
what's the next step when the pendulum
swings well you're getting awarded for
doing nothing
so you're you're basically not good at
whatever it is you're supposed to be
doing but we're going to give you things
anyway
people have learned that victimhood
weakness is prized above strength we've
created we
we used to we used to be a culture that
was too much
in my opinion uh prioritizing pure
strength
and then you you know i think there's a
happy happy medium where we're like well
we gotta lean towards merit
you gotta be good at what you do we
definitely want to protect people who
aren't as good we don't want people
dying in the streets that's ridiculous
but now we're flipped in the other
direction if you're really good at what
you do you're a problem
you're privileged yeah you know oh man
you know from my perspective and i'll
just give a biblical perspective
is i think it's an attack on god's image
you know because if you
take a biblical perspective you know men
are designed to be men right and there's
always been an attack on masculinity
why why is it wrong why is it evil
why is it twisted for a man to want to
be
who he is we've gotten to the point
where that's fine listen
if you if you want to say who you are
whatever you want to live in la la land
you want to identify
as a unicorn then go fine go do that
that's fine but don't force me
don't force me to have to to to have to
live like that
and address you the same way see that's
where i defer because there's always
this attack
attack on who we are as people if i want
to be
a masculine male that's okay
that's fine because that's who i am it's
not racist
it's not misogynist it's not uh
demeaning women
no it's normal why can't i be who i am
tim why can't i be who i am in 2020 wait
wait
you're okay why you're not white but why
can't i be who i am
there's there are millions of people out
there that are like why can't i be a
masculine man
i love going out i love you know getting
dirty uh not in a weird sexual way
some people might but you know i love
going out getting my hands dirty
putting my hands on things being a man's
man that's what i love to do
but now bro but now it's toxic why
because because uh some some leftist and
a think tank said so
because they had some weird statistic in
their college or they had some weird
upbringing
i don't care why can't i just be who i
am
you want you want to know i noticed
something and this i believe this has
been actually been proven in several
studies
and several other uh individuals on big
youtubers i know have talked to me about
this
you go to the rnc and what do you
typically see
the dudes are all tall chiseled rugged
you know
the women are all slim and busty and
attractive
you go to the dnc what do you see the
guys are all short
frumpy overweight and unattractive and
the women are overweight as well
and that was i was i was reading
something about why that is
and the general idea that i've come up
with as because i was reading something
about the trend being true generally at
you know
republicans have excused slightly
towards more attractive
and i uh whether or not it's true
because of one study is is you know not
the point i will say you know
anecdotally i've witnessed this
and i was talking to another person i
don't want to drag them into this but
they're a high profile youtuber who
covers politics who mentioned they
notice this as well and they're on the
left
and so my conclusion is it's really
simple actually if you're a very
you know tall deep voiced attractive man
you're gonna get
through life easier than a short week
you know out of shape man and you're
going to then think if i could do it on
my own
everyone else can too or at least you'll
be like i want to be left alone and
succeed on my own because i've done
better on my own
because people are more likely to favor
you or help you because you're an
attractive tall commanding individual
leadership might be easier easier for
you in fact when i used to do
fundraising for non-profits there were
two big factors
that and i'm just going to say it's true
if the dude was tall
he would raise more money than everybody
else and if the woman was just like your
your average slim attractive woman
absolutely would raise more money than
everybody else it was very very obvious
there were things like people like tall
guys tall guys
you know are commanding and people take
them seriously so you take an individual
like that
more likely to succeed and have an
easier go of doing these jobs
they're going to be republicans talking
about individualism and being left alone
let me survive on my own
you take these other people who are
unattractive and out of shape and they
struggle
so they band together and form
collectives and then vote for
collectivism
because life isn't easy you know and i
and i understand that but at the same
time i think it it has to do with what
we prize
because why like let whatever if you're
not you know like baron trump
you know you're like pushing he's like
six fights yeah you're gonna be like
seven foot you're not lebron james
you're not
this like alpha male figure like
maybe maybe you're called to just be an
honest father
maybe you just gotta maybe you're called
to be a faithful
husband maybe you're called to be uh an
amazing mom
like there's like you know i think the
american dream has been so skewed where
it's attached with like a monetary value
or it's attached with fame i think it
has to do with what
our prize is you know some people they
prize being an amazing mother which is
fine you know and i
hold those because we need that right
now especially in the black community
the black community
is suffering from father figures right
now
i would you know lebron james the dude's
a joke but i think right now we need to
uphold we need to up uplift um
black male fathers those
people need to be highlighted in the
media more than lebron james right now
because the black community doesn't need
lebron james the black community needs
fathers wasn't he a good father though i
mean he might be
but he's not somebody his role his role
in the media
is not as such kobe was an amazing
father yeah right
we need more figures like that but his
message could be whatever he wants
but right now i think people need they
need to focus on what they value the
most and right now it's okay
to just be a mother it's okay to just be
a father it's okay
prize something like that because
children need that right
this is a tough conversation i don't i
i'm not a big fan of the racial
components of saying like
the black community needs this i'm like
no everybody needs yeah everyone but
right now the black community the
fatherlessness right now in the black
community
is is is is huge it's huge well this is
this this is the challenge right
if you get specific then you start
looking at these statistics
then you know what i say i defer to
canis owens for instance
because far be it for me to tell her
what her community needs but she's
definitely brought this up
and i think kanye west has as well yeah
which is why it's so interesting that
black lives matter wants to disrupt the
nuclear family structure
which really does help people out a lot
it it's tough communist manifesto
but i'll tell you this what i think
we're seeing right now with a lot of
this
is we went through a period where we
accepted negative rights
i have a negative right to life liberty
pursuit of happiness meaning
you leave me alone but the left is now
starting to assert they have a positive
right
to life liberty and life liberty and
pursuit of happiness which is a really
interesting thing
i was talking a friend of mine who said
health care is a human right and i said
how do you have a right to someone
else's labor
and he said because how can you have
life liberty and pursuit of happiness
without you know healthcare whatever and
i'm like bro you're talking positive
rights you know that means
yeah you have no positive right to
things from me
and i was you know and i was saying like
you we have government programs and
services
you don't you have access to and you
have a right to them in the sense that
you can apply like everybody else but
they can terminate that's not a right
you have a right to free speech
you can go out and say for the most part
whatever you want the way the way i i
always structure
the way i view this the way rights are
is for the most part negative rights
like
if you were in the middle of the woods
by yourself what can you do you can
freely move around you can say whatever
you want
you can you can sharpen a stick into a
weapon defend yourself you can grow food
you can live
and you can be left alone yeah and those
are your rights anybody who comes and
tries to interfere with those you've
right to defend yourself
but tell me about your positive right to
to life liberty and pursuit of happiness
ain't nobody in the forest is going to
help you there's no one there
you're not going to get health care from
this you're going to be on your own
exactly
so when people say like you've got to
call me this name that's a positive
assertion towards their
identity a positive right you don't have
that you have a negative right
meaning you can you know you're free to
exist as you are
but you can't tell me what i have to do
within reason
right you know we have laws to prevent
certain things i think one of the big
challenges we're having
right now as well is that in these big
cities everybody lives on top of each
other
and that's when your rights are gone you
know so where where we are right now
kind of out in the suburbs
i can be pretty i can play music way way
late because
you know it might be a little noisy to a
certain degree but people aren't going
to hear me in their homes
you live in new york you can't have a
drum kit i don't i don't know where in
new york you get to
rent a warehouse or something yeah maybe
maybe you're rich enough to own the
building or be on the roof but
any one of these apartments you can't
play music you can't play drums you
can't sing
neighbors will complain and you can't
cook nasty food you know what durian is
it's like this uh east asian fruit that
smells like a rotting corpse
and so like you go to thailand and you
walk on the train and there are signs
saying no durian
because it smells so awful apparently it
tastes great
like i i was told it tastes like a
creamy almond almost
but you can't if you if you cracked one
of these things open an apartment
building in new york they would revolt
they'd be banging on your the cops would
probably come in looking for the body
that's how bad it is
we need to get more people to be like
pioneers
why don't we get some people to actually
i don't know go out into the rural area
and start building stuff
you know just start farming start
building
new things we have our culture our
culture has been so invaded
right our culture is programmed right
now to want money
fame sex everything pleasure right that
makes you
valued in life that makes you valued to
our culture right
uh no one values being a good father no
one values
uh you know being the best that they
could be if you're a mailman or
no one values being the best that they
could be if you work at a warehouse or
anything like there's
there's no glory in that there's no
value in that like and i'll put it this
way
like with my career with where i'm at
right now and
the amazing things that god has blessed
me to do they mean nothing
if i'm not amazing to my wife
if i don't love my wife if i if i beat
my wife
if i'm a total uh just complete jerk to
my wife and she's miserable
and she she's a she just she just hates
our marriage what does all this mean
it means nothing and because my values
are different i would rather be
the best husband in the world than a
political commentator or what i'm doing
right now dude
think about this you know there's that
old trope nobody ever
nobody on their deathbed ever said i
wish i spent more time at the office you
ever hear that
it's it's a saying where they're trying
to tell you to be there for your family
that family is the most important thing
you ever see that movie click with adam
sandler oh yeah
it's like multiple times watching that
movie well but i was upset by it because
they took this really fun idea of having
a remote control that can control the
universe and then turned it into some
weird story about
weird rules that took his family away
from i don't know whatever the point is
the whole movie was like don't sacrifice
your life for a career have a family and
be there for your kids
these people don't have families yeah
they don't have kids
so they don't have anything to care
about yeah
that's that's the problem they could
they don't they
they man i see these posts dude i was
talking to a friend of mine
who told me that she got her her tubes
like tied and cauterized
like like wow and
i was just like my my first response i
know this is gonna get me the feminists
are gonna get so mad at me
i said something like four billion years
of evolution just came to a grinding
halt with you
four billion generations of successful
reproduction stopped at you
and but she's a good friend of mine she
laughed and she was like i get it but
you know
i'm happy this is the choice i made and
whatever and i was just like
it was it was meant to be kind of silly
you know look you can make jokes like
that with your friends i'm sure a bunch
of feminists are screaming
but it's true though yep that's scary
that every
single person who came before you
successfully had a family
even that weird little like slimy fish
thing that had like a tiny little nub
for arms
had babies and those babies had had two
nubs and then eventually it was like
in the in the shallow parts of the water
and then eventually they had a bunch of
babies and some were coming up on the
water
and now here you are monkeys and all
that stuff and you know primates lemurs
whatever it is i don't know whatever
so here we are tim i don't know if you
remember but a while ago we were reading
research about what people value
and what people think other people value
do you remember the conclusions they
found for women
women think that followers right or
what's valued yeah but they themselves
value having families
everyone said family right they they
asked everybody what do you value and
what do you
what do other people what do you think
other people value and everyone was like
other people value fame
i value family everybody said that
you know and there's secrecy there's
probably so many fathers listening to me
right now
like we don't we need that right now
america needs
those kind of figures right now like
even though you may never be known
even though you may never get a
documentary made about you even though
you may never be in the spotlight
the kids that you have been entrusted
with the wife that you've been entrusted
with that's enough
that's enough for you let that be enough
you don't need a million dollars you
don't need to be in the spotlight you
need to be
where you are right now and being the
best version of that right now
and that's that's that's valuable tim
like why
who told us that that's not valuable
like you're only valuable if you're brad
pitt and angelina jolie and your
marriage only lasts like x amount of
years and you have all these kids and
now all these kids don't even know who
their parents are
and now you've got another girlfriend
and the divorce it goes on and on and on
and on and on and on again and
it just it's a chain reaction i think
it's more valuable right now
to get back to our moral principles to
allow ourselves to have successful
lives not just monetarily but
relationally
even friendships you know you know
what's happening is classical liberalism
is being called fascism by the far left
and think about the logical conclusion
of everything going on
we are seeing a declining birth rate
that's
i mean that's that's that's the the
issue right now
you know what's really fascinating i was
reading uh i read this pew research
study
that said generation z is the first
generation in like 100 plus years to
tick slightly conservative
they're still very much like millennials
like you know progressive sjw but a
little bit more conservative just a
little bit on some things
you know why that is it's not because
there was a r
you know a revelation among many young
people where they were like millennials
are dumb
it's because in the early 2000s there
was a report produced talking about
birth rates that found that liberals
have a less than replacement birth rate
and conservatives had a
marginally above replacement birth rate
which meant that 20 years from then
now young people are more likely to be
conservative
because conservatives were more likely
to have kids
that crazy also too and i don't i don't
have any
you know studies to back this up but i
just
being a young person right you know like
growing up especially like
i was around like the punk rock and
skateboard scene in socal and it was
just like
there's just always that sense of
rebellion in you like i want to rebel
against what is mainstream and i think
mainstream is kind of being like this
sjw right now
but i think the next generation coming
up is kind of like
i don't want to be that imagine being i
want to be the opposite you know
because i just want to be like a douche
and just do it could you imagine being
one of these like
18 year old gen z like total conformist
pro-biden losers
this is the craziest thing to me dude
it's like
when i was young i hated both parties i
hated the system i was like y'all are
dumb i don't care i'm going to do my
thing
f you i'm out yep now i'm seeing these
videos
and it's like you get all these gen z
people being like orange men bad and i'm
like that's so cute of you to copy what
the corporations are doing that's like
so very conformist stuff they're just on
snapchat tick-tock all day
but it's like being propagandized i you
know it's it's
it's it's i wouldn't say it's too
dissimilar from those that are that are
you know
sycophantic towards trump but there was
a really funny post i was reading
i love it when these lefties like to say
things like tim poole would have been
opposed to civil rights if he was eliza
alive in the 50s
and you know it's really funny because
my family is mixed race and i'm like bro
you
you you don't get to say that that
literally makes no sense i'm totally in
favor of all of those things
there was a a story i was reading where
like a teacher was talking to these kids
and the k the teacher asked the kids do
you think you would have been an
abolitionist
in the 1800s and they all said yes and
he said then tell me what it is today
that you which which idea you've
publicly supported that is unpopular and
would get you fired from your jobs
or would get you ostracized or banned
from the internet and
nobody had anything to say no one and
the point being made was
in the 1800s like early 1800s abolition
was
unpopular and these people were like
frowned upon and shunned but they knew
what was right and they stood for it and
they ultimately won
today i guess the the point of the story
was that
if if you are just going along with
what's what's the saying
if you ever find yourself on the side of
the majority you need to stop and
self-reflect
who was it was that mark twain or
something yeah i think so yeah
all of these young people i'm not
surprised by it they're being told by
the machine
you know to conform be put in this
little box and they just go along with
it
and that makes total sense like all the
people i know who went to college
i'm like did you even stop to think for
two seconds before you did this
no now they got 100k in debt they're
demanding everyone else pay for it
i was at a when i was in chicago before
kenosha broke we were documenting some
of the black lives matter
rallies protests in the city and they
specifically had one we went to a
specific one because it was a it was
high school
occupied a bunch of high school kids
right and they had the media there abc
was there they were all there
um they were giving speeches on live tv
one of the activists jumps on the mic
and she says
police chicago pd are hunting us this is
the word she used
it's all on camera like i said last
night go to my twitter lives matter show
you can see it i have nothing to hide
us hunting geez we're being hunted on
live
tv she said this so the next day
right i'm walking around downtown
chicago and uh i just
happened to walk past a group of police
officers
that were holding down uh a security
checkpoint because the looting like
elijah told you guys
there's blocks just secured right now
and it was a high-end retail
area and what do i see across the street
from the police officers
a group of black women in a high-end
retail restaurant
laughing right enjoying themselves
probably eating a plate that probably
cost maybe like 65
not being hunted of course how much of
that is happening
on a daily basis what the lies when they
come out and say something
and people believe it and but here
here's what i want to point out
there were teenagers teenagers
that were being used to put out this
kind of propaganda and i think that
needs to be highlighted because
these are minors you can easily
manipulate their minds
i was talking to a friend of mine you
know very very adamant progressive
who was like you don't understand people
are dying
every day and i said who what what
who is dying dude george floyd did you
paying attention i know i know but you
said people more than one person
i i just didn't know if there was
another story of another person they're
like well
tons of people have died like the cops
were killing people and i was like how
many
tons how many they're like i don't i
don't i don't know
does it matter and i'm like i mean to be
cl to be completely honest
you said people are dying every day i'm
just asking for the number i think one
person dying we should we should talk
about why that happened
but sometimes accidents happen like you
know guy gets in a car accident
we don't immediately say like you know
reform all cars
shut down all you know accelerators all
cars must go a static 20 miles an hour
that's
we don't do that we just say oh that was
unfortunate that shouldn't have happened
and sometimes people make mistakes while
driving we say that was their fault but
you know
it was an accident you know what i find
ridiculous is
you know because i instantly want to
come out and say well you know what
about david dorn
right his black life did he matter right
but a leftist sjw
whatever they'll come out and say it's
we're not talking about that right now
we're talking about police brutality and
i'm just like
why why why just that then why why just
why just that if black lives matter why
don't all black lives matter
if black lives matter then why don't
why doesn't every single black life that
is
unjustifiably taken blasted in the media
why but i know the answer to this
question you know the answer to this
question but i'm saying these things
because i know there are people watching
that have probably never even thought
about that before
why because like i said earlier it's a
political tool
in their hand and it only
sensationalizes
black people getting unjustly shot by
police
because it furthers a particular goal of
abolishing the police exactly of
abolishing prisons
and that is the only end result for
getting rid of police and prisons
is just the deterioration and chaos
there's no
like so this is there's a problem and to
bring in their new regime there's no
there's not going to be a new regime i
think that would be they think that no
it'll be roving bands
of you know idiots with baseball bats
and purple hair smashing things up
it will not be fun but there's not gonna
be a regime look at libya
okay it's gonna be warring factions for
a hundred years
and you know who's gonna take over do
you think it's gonna be the sjw
you know loonies who are who are crying
and only powerful because they swarm
people with their friends
or do you think it's gonna be the
commando like militias and
more right-wing ultra-traditionalists
who protect their women
and and the women agree with it yeah
they're going to go out i mean we here
all the time we talk about civil war
the right likes to say look who's got
the guns and i'm like that's
not the case okay let me just put this
simply for you if the far left is
gaining a foothold in the government and
they're
expanding this ideology and we get this
guy this antifa guy going on tv claiming
he was just defending a person of color
and that works
then the civil war won't be about who
has the guns it'll be about who controls
the government and the military yep
that's the point
yep so there will be cars racing to the
white house and it's going to be biden
and trump both declaring victory
both running up to the secret service
and going arrest him
and the secret service is going to go
who's going to get arrested and patriots
in the secret service patriots in the
military patriots in the national guard
patriots in lapd police departments
they're all going to have to start
making some serious decisions
who do you serve do you serve the
constitution of the united states or do
you serve these radical authoritarians
that's not that's not that's that's not
correct because the people on the far
left think they are serving the
constitution
they they assert that trump is the one
violating the constitution but they're
not
but they're not what violence that
that's that's not
that's not that's accurate in their
heads that's what they may think sure
so but all that's not what's reality but
it doesn't matter if they think it
they'll draw a gun and exactly put their
bullets at it
so what's going to happen is you're
going to end up with biden and trump
speeding up
you know getting out of their cars
yelling arrest him i'm this is an
exaggerated like you know fictionalized
scenario
dramatized scenario it'll be something
this effect i guess
and then what's the what's the person
going to think what media do they watch
if cnn comes out and says definitive
proof donald trump cheated and facebook
shuts down trump's account so trump
can't speak biden wins
hands down because they're going gonna
be like the only thing i heard is that
donald trump is trying to cheat so we're
gonna protect
joe biden yep the narrative will be
donald trump
lost he doesn't want to leave the white
house
therefore we have to go in there and
forcibly what did nancy pelosi
say uh drag him out or something no she
used uh like bug spray term
what is it when you uh your house give a
gate fumigator
imagine that imagine uh the speaker of
the house saying uh you know we might
have to fume again
at all well the military uh at least
some
gates have said they won't intervene but
i'm i don't know what's gonna happen i
think
i think what's gonna happen is you're
gonna see what in this war game article
they wrote they said alternative media
will start spreading
lies defending trump that's why that's
the game they're going to they're
setting all of us up
they're setting us up to be the liars
they're setting us up even though we may
be bearers of truth the propaganda
remember what i told you guys last night
and you already know this is the the
narrative gets
set months years ahead that's what all
these articles are
so people are already being programmed
to anticipate something male in voting
is
safe ignore all the evidence to
anticipate that this could possibly
happen
oh we want to be on the right side of
history i don't i don't want to be shot
or something i don't want to be a
a scene looking like i'm resisting a
free election
no this is propaganda and people need to
understand
this is being set the stage is being set
for the election
to be uh in my undermined undermined
yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all next time
you